but first with the details from his
breaking news report is the hills John
Solomon alright let's let's start at the
beginning here because we have talked a
lot about these issues but tonight's
news is different because we have now
discovered a long email chain is that
proper way to characterize it yes that's
how it's been described to me that's
correct Shawn okay you know yours lights
are on just to get it set up whose names
are on this email chain well I'm told
that James Comey is one of them that
there are people from the National
Security Division of the Justice
Department and that they're key players
that were the obvious people involved in
the FBI though I don't have their names
working at various points on the Russia
investigation so it's a large group of
people trying to get ready to get the
spice a warrant submitted to the court
and there are two or three very
important revelations one is that James
Comey is involved in discussions too
there is mention in these emails at the
intelligence community possibly the NSA
or another agency had concerns about the
quality of the intelligence in the
Steele dossier and three that there were
pretty significant worries concerns that
Christopher Steele had already begun
talking to the news media this is before
they file the FISA warrant before they
fire him if all those things are true if
the if the FBI had not corroborated and
there were concerns about the steal
dossier
if they knew that Steele had talked to
Yahoo News and then Yahoo News is used
as a corroborating piece of evidence for
the dossier these are serious issues
they would be misleading the court with
this information by portraying it as
something more solid than it is and you
know we learned all about this
funny-funny from really two appearances
on Fox News over the holiday week Devon
Nunez showed up on a Maria Bartiromo
show in your show and he said hey I kind
of amended my request for the
declassification no one followed up and
so we started asking questions and we
found out there's an email trail and it
may be some of the more damning in late
belated produced evidence that may
suggest wrongdoing at the FBI let's go
through this slowly so we have now
evidence that you have uncovered email
chains from these people and the FBI DOJ
work that are at the top levels and what
we now know is is they knew that this
was not verified this dossier
they knew that it where it came from
that Hillary had paid for it they never
took the time to verify it themselves
and rather than do their due diligence
they went along and just decided that
they wanted to get the the FISA warrant
and they committed what is ultimately a
conscious fraud on the court is that a
fair characterization I think that's the
question in the allegation that has to
be further investigate until we see the
actual language of this email I don't
want to pass judgment but I can tell you
people who have seen it or have been
involved with that email say directly
it's among the most damning evidence of
wrongdoing by the FBI if those people
see it and if Devon Nunez thought it was
important enough to bother the President
and asked him to declassify this among
the other documents I think we should
assume it's a very important piece of
evidence so how could anybody justify
not telling the court key pieces of
information before you know we have a
quote of rod Rosenstein it was back in
May when he said when you're talking
about a FISA you know you have a career
of law enforcement official and they put
their signature that that's the Full
Faith and Credit bill 'ti that they're
putting behind that warrant yeah but
they never verified it and now we know
that they even suspected themselves that
none of it was true
in many ways but it never stopped them
because their desire to get that warrant
far exceeded a desire to do it in a use
the proper process and processes and do
due diligence and they wanted it more
than they wanted to follow the law and
they purposely kept information that is
pertinent from the judges that's fair
right yeah I think that's definitely I
think that is now not in dispute anymore
let's think about what we know Sean for
sure
indisputable the core evidence for the
FISA warrant that's Andy McCain's
description without it we would not have
pursued the FISA warrant came from a
product paid for by Hillary Clinton and
the Democratic Party to try to destroy
Donald Trump in the final months of the
election we know that the people who
handle that evidence prepared and tried
to rush it through the FBI to the court
were two agents who on their own said
they wanted to stop Donald Trump from
becoming president
we know the person who created the
dossier doesn't stand by it he says he
knew it was uncorroborated intelligence
when he submitted it and he himself
despised Donald Trump and despite all
that and now the NSA or some other
intelligence community agency having
concerns about the dossier and the FBI
knowing the journal is the journalist
say we're going to play Straub reading
where you all of that all of that's now
not disputed and yet we think this is a
good product I think that's the question
that that we need to have answer why did
this move forward with all these flaws
these aren't just flaws they knew it was
fraudulent and their desire to get Trump
I would argue far exceeds it by other
evidence so now the question is the
president before the election talked
about unredacted and releasing the FISA
applications that has not happened yet
gang of eight information that has not
happened yet the 302s would Bruce or and
Christopher steel that has not happened
yet and the president recently said well
I might do it at the appropriate time if
this is the fight that the Democrats in
Congress want to have but this is the
fourth bucket as we call it that
Tevin Nunez was talking about that
everybody knew everybody knew that this
was phony
this basically they created and
fabricated a lie at bet at worst a story
to the court and withheld exculpatory
information that would have prevented
any judge from ever granting a FISA
warrant the president release it so I
think his lawyers and he have come up
with a prudent concept and my reporting
indicates that he still is committed as
ever to releasing these documents but
listen the first thing that will
vindicate the president is if Robert
Muller finishes into investigation the
president's not charged with any crimes
right he wants to get this over with
he's fearful and his lawyers are fearful
that if he releases the documents before
them he'll be accused of tampering or
trying to sway the investigation at the
last minute it's on e winding down let
it wind down is what the president is
lawyers I think are thinking according
to my reporting and then we can have
this debate about how this thing
originated and all the flaws that
occurred and try to make sure it doesn't
happen again to some other person in the
future I think that's the process he's
following John Solomon great reporting
thank you thank you so this is huge
we'll have more on this later in the
show all right